this is kalon wall City also known as
the densest city in the world here's the
density of La New York Hong Kong and
Calon and it almost tripled in
population in just a couple decades the
buildings were packed so tightly
together that they literally grew into
each other and the only way to get
around was through these dark and
complicated network of alleys rules and
government regulations were pretty much
non-existent so it was full of crime and
almost subhuman living conditions but it
also had its own ecosystem with shops
clinics and even schools because
businesses didn't have to meet any
safety or labor regulations they could
produce things at a fraction of a cost
and so industry kind of thrived there
attracting more and more people looking
for opportunities in fact lots of things
made in secretly made their way back
to the rest of the world so how could a
city like this even happen I made a
video looking into the callon wall City
if you want to learn more follow the
link right here